all right guys
bang bang i've got george here super
excited to have this conversation thank
you so much for doing this sir
you're welcome it's really exciting to
be on the pump show
for sure let's just start with your
background you're obviously doing a
bunch of really interesting and
incredible things today
in the psychedelic space but let's first
start just kind of where did you grow up
and how did you start
in your business career oh
sure i grew up outside of philadelphia
pennsylvania was born in 55
i'm actually adopted also which is um
you know
really grateful to the people who
adopted me and grew up in that
environment i then went off to
school i went to a preparatory school
in outside of philadelphia called the
haverford school
and had a great education there went off
to university
and all along the way i was sort of
interested in a combination
of technology which was just getting
started then this was really early days
of computers so
i was really intrigued in doing computer
programming and so forth so i was a bit
of a geek as a teenager
and one of the things i found actually
really interesting was some of the work
that was being done in psychedelics at
that time
this was late 60s early 70s with cancer
patients and obviously that's a theme
that's continued
i was also really interested in
psychology and so
i brought those things together in
university and graduate school as
working in cognitive science looking at
attention and consciousness
then i got some clinical training i was
really interested in clinical psychology
but i realized kind of toward the end of
my training that
i didn't want to work one person at a
time there are people who
love that who get great meaning for it
but i really wanted to look at how we
could work
at a system level and so that really
started to
point me more toward business away from
academia away from research
and my first company was something
called the human interface
group which was in 85 i created it it
was really to help
people who are going through large-scale
technology change with
influx of computer-grade manufacturing
this was really going on in the mid-80s
i was really interested in the human
side how did jobs change how do people
change
et cetera and that really started a long
career that focused on different aspects
of collaboration
um and so for me i've always been
interested in that i built businesses
around it
sold one to lotus one was a software
development to support collaboration
then went on and focused on
collaboration across businesses that
really took place in the early days of
the internet
another organization called tamar lab
and then joined forces with mckinsey and
company and
did a bunch of work there and the most
interesting thing that i
started to get curious about was the
interaction between governments and
business
and collaboration there because this was
right around the top
of time of the major scandal some of
your folks may have heard of enron and
so forth but
this is when public trust in large
companies started to go away and for
very good reason
and i became really interested in what
is the role of the regulator and how
does he actually
or that function of regulation affect
society and i created a bit of a wonky
business called tapestry networks which
really was to
bring people who were kind of at the
leading edge of
um good ethics in companies audit
committee chairman
to actually start looking and sharing
best practices learning from worst
practices and starting to engage with
you know people like the sec just to
learn how to implement
sarbanes-oxley which was going on at the
time so
you know very very focused in terms of
how do we look at
the responsibility we have as business
leaders to
operate ethically effectively and
how do we work with regulators to make
sure that we discharge duties
appropriately
then lastly that took me down the stream
to
do some work in healthcare and and
similar issues similar regulated
industry
looking at how do we get the right
medicines to the right patients at the
right time
and here's a really important bit at a
cost society can afford
right so not only do we have to worry
about safety and
efficacy but the really big thing is if
we have something that works it better
be accessible for as many people as
possible a great society could afford
and that led me to move to the uk where
health care is actually a right not a
privilege
and so it's available for everyone and i
think that
you know working on this issue across
europe has really helped inform some of
my
work that was also you know involving
the us
as well so that was kind of what i my
career arc always about collaboration
always about getting to a better answer
usually with together and usually with a
real focus on
improving the quality of people's lives
i love that life mission
uh one of the things that has come to
the forefront especially during this
pandemic where governments have forced
people to sit inside
is mental health and obviously it's much
easier
to kind of measure the people who get
sick the people who die
but there's definitely a rise in mental
health issues
uh depression um and it feels
like maybe over the last five to ten
years
that has come to the forefront in
general but it was really really
accelerated
uh by covid and kind of all of the
government mandated shutdowns
can you talk to me a little bit just
about that problem
in general how you view it uh and maybe
what some of the effective or
non-effective
types of um you know treatments
historically have been there
yeah it's a pretty big question pumped
but you're you're renowned for that so
i'll
take it um look i i think first and
foremost um we
we're a mental health care company you
mentioned psychedelics but i think we
just see that as a really
interesting important tool that has a
long history
a long a lot of learning to be built
upon
but we have an opportunity now to look
at it as a tool to really
improve and transform mental health and
why is that important specifically today
well as you mentioned
you know just looking at depression just
one whole area of mental
ill health if you will it is almost
bigger in terms of its impact on society
and patients and cancer and diabetes
together it's huge um it is
uh just you know the people who have
said that they are depressed or in
treatment is about over 300 million
people worldwide
um it's estimated that one in five one
in six people will
experience that sometime in their life
and
you know we've been really making good
progress in the late 80s around
some new treatments kind of the
traditional antidepressants for that
um but when you look at it hard you see
that about
30 of people aren't helped by
traditional antidepressants
when you use that as a multiplier on
that over 300 million you quickly get to
over 100 million
suffering with depression being
disconnected from their lives
disconnected from their loved ones
disconnected from a sense of purpose
really kind of in a deep inner kind of
conversation often and and removed from
the life that they want to live
quite often and to have 100 million
people suffering from that and it
actually has to be more because
the stigma that you talked about still
exists around the world
it's a big problem and while we're
making some progress
historically we have a huge opportunity
with that many people who are suffering
and perhaps suffering unnecessarily
and so covid actually i think the
intersection of covid
and the intersection of a demographic
i think is changing things and the
demographic are
people who are part of the first
medicated generation
with psych meds and this started in the
late 90s
with children on both sides of the
atlantic which in areas that we focus in
on but more in america
and i think people became very much more
comfortable talking about this
uh much more familiar with kind of the
use of medicines even as children
and i think this kind of openness has
reduced stigma i think parents who use
these tools have reduced stigma
and i think covet has just said look
this is a huge
problem we're all feeling it no matter
whether we've had a history of this or
not
it's hard kind of talking to you know
these little squares on screens and
calling that contact and relationships
so i think we're seeing a confluence of
things in terms of reduction of stigma
broadly around mental health production
of stigma around
people are looking at these new
substances like psychedelics is a
possible approach we could take at least
we need to look at it and
a reduction kind of this huge unmet need
that's bubbling up
all around us so i think it's the right
time to
have this conversation and more
importantly the right time to do the
really hard work ahead
to see if these are good tools to
transform mental health for all those
people who aren't helped
yeah and talk a little bit about kind of
the founding of compass and kind of what
the
impetus uh for the idea was and where
you guys started
well so i was busy
doing this work i had mentioned on
health systems also
you know working continually in
corporate governance and how to have
effective governance and
so that was going on i had the wonderful
event in my life of meeting someone
amazing who i
got married to katya
my wife my co-founder a doctor someone
who is
just incredibly committed to making a
difference for patients that's been her
life work and someone who also had a
research background
and she brought her you know her son was
16 when we got married he was going off
to university incredibly smart talented
high energy person they're really
interesting to be around he went to
university and then started really
suffering with depression and ocd and
anxiety
and you know we thought well how how
difficult could this be we you know
we're therapists thank god we live in
the united states we do have some access
to care
um you know we're so much more fortunate
than so many others are
um this shouldn't be difficult and so
that started a journey to help him and
he just became worse and worse with all
the medicines he was in that 30 percent
that aren't helped
and you know with combinations of things
it just turned into trial and error
where there was more error and
and it just didn't work and that led
katya on her sleepless nights as a mom
to start doing research it led her to
become board certified in
integrative and holistic medicine she
was an internist so it helped her
understand this world of psychiatry if
she were here she'd say you know she
prescribed antidepressants for patients
who were suffering but she you know
wasn't a psychiatrist
and and this really started our journey
of how to help him and
in that journey we found psilocybin
research she found psilocybin research
with ocd a study by moreno
and that really kind of excited her
because it showed promise and something
that was just so
kind of lots of dead ends in the past so
that led us to get
try to get smart as we do try to meet
the people who are doing the work
incredibly brave thoughtful researchers
working at the leading edge
of looking at these substances which
have been you know just
really vilified and not looked at
um so they took a lot of personal risk
you know teams like johns hopkins
griffiths matt johnson uh steve ross
uh his team up at nyu
robin carhart harris david nut at
imperial
franz folenveter charlie grove at ucla
and these are incredibly
important pioneering studies they did
and we became really intrigued by that
we
spent time we provided some financial
resources along the way to help them as
donors to get started
and the more we saw the more we realized
that
given the work i had been doing and
given what we were seeing that there was
kind of a missing step to get this to
patients
and that was large-scale well-funded
studies
that were done to the highest standards
globally because it's a global problem
it's not a u.s problem but it is a u.s
problem but it is a global problem too
and so you know if we had promise
why not try to do this at that scale
going back
to my earliest days that i referred to
which is one to one is beautiful work
scaling is where you can create
opportunities for lots of that
one-to-one so that's kind of our focus
and that took us into kind of a thought
experiment about well how do we do this
and so the first port of call was
talking to regulators with whom i had
the benefit of working in the past
and just sharing some of the early
signals that excited us and it excited
them
and then we decided well it's time to
see what we can do to contribute and so
when you first start going down
uh kind of this path if you will uh talk
at kind of a high level about
psychedelics and and some of the um
you know understandings that we do have
and some of the understandings that we
don't have
as an industry and how you view this is
this just a medicinal
type activity is this something that you
think will eventually become
recreational
and how you see you know really using
this
uh on the front of mental health
um you know given that you're building
one of the leading companies in the
space like just how do you view
uh psychedelics in general before we get
into some of the specific things you
guys are doing well
again i've got to maybe helicopter up a
bit
and say how do we review mental health
and then how do we view psychedelics so
mental health
is a huge spectrum of
life experiences and we call mental
health when
people aren't suffering from the way
they experience life
we call mental illness where they are
really suffering significantly or
disconnected debilitated
unable to participate in their life and
and worse from there
there's a large gray area in that that
we don't really
fully understand what the boundaries are
when you develop a medicine it's always
working in the
area of the greatest unmet need first
because
that's where we we know that whatever
risk of treatment there is even if
there's benefit
the benefit a small benefit for someone
who's really suffering
is really a good thing for someone who's
kind of having
bad days here and there and you take on
more risk then it's harder to say where
the benefit
risk boundary should be and so this is
really the core
aspect of regulation it's the core
aspect of
how we provide care to people in in a
medical environment is understanding
this balance of risk and benefit
and for whom so if katy were here she
would say you know
we know a lot about mental illness there
are books written about it you know they
have the dsm
diagnostic statistical manual and
there's hundreds of pages describing
everything about mental illness
it's much harder to find a book on
mental health
and so we have this really well-defined
territory and that's really where the
medical area is focused
and the reason we're focused in our
areas we didn't try to be clairvoyant as
i said you know one of the problems that
pharmaceutical companies have had in the
past is
they develop things and then they try to
convince people that
they're worthwhile and we
what i learned in all my work with
regulators and payers and health systems
is that
if we start the other way around and say
where's the need and how might we help
that's really important place to start
and that's what how we started compass
we went to
regulators and health systems insurers
and said where is your biggest problem
or this might help and they kept coming
back with this notion of treatment
resistant depression
and that's a weird title
treatment resistant depression right
it's a weird construct
because the depression isn't resisting
and the patients that we've met who
suffer with this aren't resisting
it's really a convenient way to say we
don't know what to do
right now to help you and the
traditional medicines don't work so
we'll try a bunch of things and
yes the words the treatment seems not to
be working
um and but these people i don't know no
one's
that we've met is resisting treatment
what they're doing is really trying to
find something that works for them
and that's really the opportunity that's
measured in you know 100 million people
and that's where we're starting to focus
now
when we look at psychedelics i think
one of the things that happens is we
have to think about well what is
depression and there are lots of
different views and perspective on this
but
one thing that's really been interesting
kind of in most recent work
on depression for leading edge work is
looking at depression as a
an issue of cognition the way we think
not the way we feel
we're feeling kind of as a cascade
but the way we think the scientists
often talk about what's called negative
attentional bias you can think of
negative attentional bias as people who
wear a different colored glass
than rose-colored people who tend to see
things in a negative fashion they tend
to expect
the worst not the best they tend to
operate sometimes from a feeling of
scarcity rather than abundance
and not because there's anything wrong
with them it's how they've
learned it's how they've processed
information it's an environment
and sometimes people get very captivated
by these thoughts and they start
thinking more and more and they become
ruminating and they kind of
you know turn things over again and
again and again in their mind
and the more you look at it the kind of
the worse it gets the
worse it gets the more internally
focused you become the less engaged you
are with your life maybe the less fun
you are to hang out with
um you know all of these things
contribute to kind of a falling in and
on ourselves in our thoughts
and i think that one of the things
that's
really important is that psilocybin and
based on some very recent research in
the last 10 years that we just didn't
understand before we didn't
know before that the last 10 years we've
there's actually a circuit of activity
in our brain
that connects different parts of our
brain and helps us
explain and make sense of the inputs
and you can also kind of think of that
as yourself
it's sort of my how i process
information
and what we know psilocybin is it can
provide in many people
at the right dose with the right support
and preparation and the right
of that network and and so
this notion of rumination and
playing over things it applies in it's a
characteristic of a number of things
broadly
in kind of the mental illness area of
depression
anxiety ocd
eating disorders where people have these
very kind of
well-worn routines of thinking
and psilocybin seems to help reset those
and so when you get the right support
when you talk about this therapy
walk me through um how exactly it works
right from like an execution standpoint
so
i have a treatment resistant depression
um i go and uh i interact with whether
it is a
a doctor or a psychologist
at some point i get to the point where i
say hey i think that this may be the
best path forward
is this something where uh i get a
prescription
um and i basically am doing this at home
am i going into a
controlled environment with like set and
setting like walk me through kind of
just how
actually um the actual therapy works
sure and i'll be very clear right now
you can't do any of those things because
this is in clinic
legally at least because this is now in
clinical trials so maybe what i'll do is
talk about how our clinical trials work
because that's real and happening today
and we'll give you a view into that in
the real world so
the first thing we have to do because a
lot of clinical trials
are difficult to assess
because they have lots of different
types of patients it's called
heterogeneity
and so the first thing we have to do is
make sure we're kind of
working on the same type of thing for
patients so the very first thing that
happens in our studies is we have to
make sure you have
quote-unquote treatment-resistant
depression that means we need medical
records to demonstrate that you've had
at least
two different antidepressants
traditional antidepressants
and you're still depressed in the same
episode
so the first thing we have to do is make
sure you're the right kind of patient so
that the data we present
actually reflects a reality right
if you give somebody you don't know what
you're giving them you don't know what
they're suffering with and you get great
results what does that tell you
so how do you do it for the next person
how do you know who helps and who is it
doesn't help so
first thing make sure you have the right
patient in our case it's two to four
prior failures of an antidepressant
and you still have a high level a medium
to high level of depression so you're
still suffering that is measured by
questionnaires and interviews
and if you have all that and you don't
have a prior history of schizophrenia
certain kinds of uncontrolled high blood
pressure
you then can come into our study now a
lot of people who
have taken antidepressants and find that
they don't work
still take them and that's
they take them because it's almost like
an insurance policy
if i stop taking them maybe i'll even
feel worse but i'm still depressed and
i'm taking them
so the very first step for us is to help
people
taper and then get off of the
traditional antidepressants
because they are thought to counteract
the effects of psilocybin
so the first thing we have to do is
what's called a therapeutic washout and
that takes a couple of weeks it's done
under
the supervision of a psychiatrist and we
do that in our studies and that's going
to happen in the real world
it's a couple weeks most people can do
it without a lot of difficulty some
people suffer flu-like
symptoms and some people actually get
worsening depression
and about the same number of people
according to prior studies
actually aren't depressed anymore when
they stop their medication and they
don't qualify for the studies anymore
because the depression goes away for
some reason we don't know if you're
not assessing causality we're just
assessing correlation
so they come off the antidepressants and
then we start talking to them
a little bit to understand their
narrative because what's really powerful
in depression is kind of how i see that
world that's that
train of thinking i mentioned and to
start understanding their story
and everyone has a story everyone has a
story about their life how it's unfolded
what it's been i told my story you have
your story we all have our stories
sometimes those stories no longer serve
us and so
we try to understand a bit in the
therapy about what the narrative is
what's the quality of that narrative for
the person
and start disconnecting them from the
narrative
it's to help them when they feel anxiety
to pay attention to where the anxiety
feels in their body not the story about
when the anxiety first happened and all
that but just pay attention to the
thought
or the feeling not the thought
disconnect them and we train people how
to do that we train people how to
manage anxiety through breathing
exercises and we give them a sense of
what it's like to have a
psilocybin experience by showing them a
little
animation we've made to educate patients
to talk about it
we answer any questions they might have
um because
we're only using 10 of people who've had
only 10
of people who participate in our trials
have had prior psychedelic experiences
because a lot of the other trials have
always focused on people who've a
greater proportion people have had these
experiences
but if we're making this as a medicine
to the whole world we have to really
make sure that it reflects the real
world and that's about no more than 10
of people so we go through all this
preparation
then the day of the actual session they
come in the morning they're instructed
to eat a light breakfast
um and they come into a pretty chilled
out environment
you know it's a couch or a bed
it's soft lighting there's two
therapist chairs one's a therapist one
is the person who's assisting that
therapist that's the way we train new
therapists
and they're basically invited to take
the medicine
which is five capsules five milligrams
each or two capsules or
one active capsule we're doing 1 10 and
25 in our trials
to see is it 10 significantly better
than the
one is the 25 even better do you have
more or less side effects with each this
is a critical aspect of
creating a medicine what's the dose
right
and what's so you've got to do that
right this is sort of
basic basic stuff um so we're doing that
and so we give people the suicide but it
might be a high medium or low dose
then we invite them based on what we
prepared them to just relax
they might look at art books they might
just listen to music we then
give them a soundtrack that we have
that's seven hours
and it's basically the soundtrack for
the session we also invite them to put
on eye shades because
the difference between recreational and
therapeutic use is really is that in an
inner or
outer experience and we're very much
about an
inner experience a deep inner experience
that's supported by others
the therapists are there to help people
deal with any anxiety they might have or
things they want to talk about
or help them you know go to the restroom
but it's not an
active therapy session it's a therapist
there to provide exquisite just-in-time
support to a person whatever they might
need
and the psilocybin session starts
about 20 to 40 minutes after people
start having a sense of
a little shift in the way the music
sounds perhaps maybe
some patterned images when their eyes
are closed
and then that builds and then they may
start having memories and
thoughts of their past life you know
things have happened in the past
um and this emerges it grows
um the music kind of was a little bit of
a carrier wave to support that over the
course of the time
music has different levels of you know
different types of emotion
it's all instrumental largely until the
very end
and it it provides a a base note
for the experience of internal
exploration
and we ask people just to you know
let emerge what emerges don't fight it
go with it be curious about
it but there's always someone there to
keep you safe keep your body safe
it's over about six or eight hours later
they
go home and then we come back and do a
debrief the next day
sorry for such long answers uh listen i
i love this
this is i think giving people a crash
course in terms of uh
you know not only one your philosophical
view
of mental health and kind of what you
guys are seeing uh
as the opportunity and really what a
potential solution looks like but also
uh to how this kind of plays out from an
execution standpoint
talk to me a little bit about kind of
the regulatory environment and i'm much
more familiar with kind of the u.s
environment than
than elsewhere there's kind of this
balance between
decriminalization legalization and then
obviously medicinal versus recreational
how do you look at regulation and is
there like a specific
framework or milestones that you're
looking for
as we kind of push forward with a lot of
the scientific research that's going on
yeah so um
you know regulation is something that
seems very scary and like going to the
principal's office for many people
right um if i think about what
regulation really is regulation grew up
and has evolved simply because the
animal spirits of capitalism
just can't stop promoting things that
might not be true
and when it comes to health care and you
get overselling
people can get hurt because you have a
vulnerable population so regulation
came out to really say if in fact you're
going to make a claim about something to
vulnerable population
we better have data you better know who
it works for who it doesn't work for
and what the risks are because these
people are vulnerable and that's really
the core
of regulation it's how do we make sure
that we are not making claims that take
people who have
hopes for a better life and somehow
take advantage of them for our own good
um
that's why regulation exists um and it's
evolved to be
you know very very complex because this
is a complicated topic
right and making sure that the same
medicine is the same everywhere on the
planet
and then when you take 10 milligrams of
it in beijing it's going to be the same
as when you take it in
boise and you know that it's to the
highest quality standards that we
know what to do you know we know how to
assess that they're huge branches of
science to do this
so regulation is about ensuring you have
a quality product
you know who will benefit you know who
won't benefit and you have data to back
it all up
and a drug is essentially a substance
that doesn't have that
a medicine is a drug plus all the
evidence
that you have that it's a quality drug
that to the highest standards possible
that it continuously improves through
the manufacturing process
that you have something that doesn't
harm people
and it actually has a benefit that's
greater than the potential harm and you
can identify who will benefit from it
who it won't so
that's what regulation is it's a
fundamental aspect of public health and
responsible
development of substances for human
beings
now we see three areas we see the
recreational
we see an emerging area that we kind of
tongue into
called the sector recreational it's
people who
you know have a sense that something
could be just a little better in their
lives or maybe
if i had a different viewpoint or it's
sort of like
personal development on steroids and
that seems to be an emerging
sector um i think that's where some of
the things like oregon and others are
looking at this
i think someone refers to the betterment
of well people above jesse
as a kind of a way to define the
recreational set
then you have vulnerable people who are
struggling to get out of their bedrooms
struggling to make it to work on
assistance desperate i mean every 40
seconds someone commits suicide someone
on the planet someone dies from suicide
so and 20 people try every 40 seconds
this is a huge problem and so
that's where we're focused given the
urgency and the need
that intersection is the medical side
and that's where regulation really comes
through
now i'll just leave this kind of for
your next question but
the the really interesting question
is when are the tools of regulation
identifying benefit and risk
identifying safety identifying the
quality of the product
when do we throw them out the window
i kind of think it's important i think
you'll see a lot of the
work that went into the oregon
legislation is to to try to answer some
of those questions so
it isn't hey try this good luck with
that
um so i think there's a really important
set of questions here we're focused on
doing it the most rigorous
medical way because that's really the
highest standard
and if we can set that standard then we
can learn from it
yeah and as you're kind of building the
company one of the things that really
stuck out to me as i looked more and
more into what you guys are doing is
kind of the company values that you guys
embody and so
um this idea of collaboration of being
transparent with the
progress that you make um the
combination of both the
medicinal drugs but also uh some of the
what i'll call softer therapy type
approach as well where do a lot of those
kind of company values come from and
why are those so important to you um
given that you know as a publicly traded
company there's this idea of just hey
we're capitalists and we're going to go
make as much money as we can
there's other things in there that maybe
aren't uh
you know counterintuitive to that but
but definitely i think would uh
would surprise people if they were
reading some of the the ways that you
guys think about the business
well i think the way everyone thinks
about business is changing
um and you know you can see some of the
largest
corporations uh moving to a focus on
stakeholders and it
has a broader view than just
shareholders so i think this change is
taking place we see it with
emergence of esg goals environment
social and governance goals
for business required reporting from
financial regulators and the people who
oversee us
so the world is changing and i think
that's for the better frankly
i think that we need to take our
responsibility particularly working with
vulnerable populations
incredibly seriously um as you know and
many of the people listening to this
know it's not easy to take a company
public
and one of the core things about doing
that for us was
being transparent so we have to have
and doing it to the highest standards so
the sec the u.s is kind of the highest
standard for disclosures
and so when you read our 300 page
document about what our plans are
you know exactly what our plans are uh
you know
exactly what the 100 pages of risks are
you know all of that is laid out so that
people can choose to participate or not
and it's our game plan and it's a game
plan that we
are viewing as how do we do the most not
the least
because if we do the most we then can
confidently look to
health systems and patients everywhere
on the planet to say look
we've done the hard work now let's
actually look at how we can help at
scale
and this is a huge problem and it needs
a really highly competent effective
approach
now values are pretty important right
because that's how you
actually have a company that performs
and delivers
and we have four sets of values and we
like the kind of
tensions and the creative tension
between them it's compassionate that's
where we start right it's even reflected
in our name
people are suffering we have to get that
we've been on the front lines you know i
had my ex-wife who said sadness passed
away
struggled with alcohol and died from
that so i think
many of us everyone has a story like
this somewhere in their life
of what that struggle looks like and
feels like
so compassion is where it all has to
start
but we also can't be because of the size
of the problem we have to be really bold
at the solution level that's another
kind of you know value for us is to be
bold think big
you know and you know really look at
what could we do
and be imaginative and hopefully we'll
get a chance to talk a little bit about
how technology plays into all this
how therapy plays into all of this how
music plays into all this you know it's
a beautiful creative experience to bring
this but we have to be bold in their
vision
because too many people are suffering
from incremental solutions
so boldness is important the next thing
that's super important to us is rigor
right
if you're bold without being rigorous
bad stuff can happen
so you know we don't want to be bold and
not have a good safety profile of our
medicine or really understand who it
helps and who it doesn't and who it
might even harm
these are all things that we have to do
with the highest level of rigor and do
it
kind of better than in some cases the
industry that's developed medicines in
the past has done
so we set a high bar that's helped
informed by boldness and compassion
lastly we have to be inclusive and this
is super important
right it's great if you know you're in a
recreational setting and can afford to
drop
somewhere 2500 5 000 for an experience
in a workshop in amsterdam or wherever
um that's not a person who's been
unemployed for
two years and struggling and on food
stamps in the u.s
and trying to get therapy through
medicaid that's not that
and so inclusive
means access it means how do we think
about reimbursable
it takes me back to my prior work an
affordable a funny word to use with
healthcare but
better be used to make it accessible so
you know we're doing a wonderful project
right now on the inclusion side a couple
of them but one of them that we're
really excited about is a project with
the grady trauma center
in you know disadvantaged communities
outside of atlanta
trying to understand how will they adopt
this you know what are the attitudes to
people who
are that population of vulnerable
suffering and we have people who are
suffering across all social strata but
to really pay attention to
access for those people that's really
important to us so inclusion is also an
important value
so this is sort of the way we you know
weave our company together
to make sure we're focused on those
valves even internally we
recognize people about how they embody
the values every month
and so georgetown yeah when you think
about kind of bringing all of this
together
right um what is the
ultimate vision for what you're building
is this something where
uh there's the clinical trials and there
are
um kind of uh biotechnology or
science based uh advancements and
ultimately
uh kind of final products that get
approved and can be used by people
there's the technology component uh in
terms of the way that you
manage care and help actually people who
need it
and then also what i'll call kind of the
therapeutic experience so whether that's
music the setting
etc is really kind of the vision to
bring those three things together
into a unified kind of
front to end um experience and product
and service
that ultimately drives at solving at
least a part
of that mental health issue is that
fair to say um it's fair to say
and maybe i'll kind of play it back in
some of the way we think about it okay
so
vision the vision is a world of mental
well-being for as many people as
possible
cool stuff by the way well-being doesn't
mean you don't have down days
well-being means that you don't kind of
just have down days
but you have a full-on personal
experience it goes from the
you know emotional ups downs that you
live a full human life
and that's what we mean by well-being
that you actually participate in your
life and
have a you know the relationships you
want and the life you wish
um now how do we get there
one of the things that is our major goal
is looking at how we
do things that are really required to
help get there for people who are
suffering
that's summarized by developing a
personalized approach
meaning it might be different for you
than for me because we're different
so how do we think about personalizing
therapy understanding doses how do
people respond who responds to what
so personalized is really important
doing research to help inform how we
personalize something because we're all
different
our life experiences are different our
stories are different
our suffering is different the next
thing is to be able to
actually provide something that is a
fast and durable single episodic single
treatment
and that's why we're so excited about
the work we're doing in psilocybin
therapy and also with other
psychedelics who are doing earlier stage
research with it's to be able to create
for a majority not everyone this is not
a cure that's so important to your
stress
you know but for many people to create
this immediate and
durable experience of a different way of
looking at things
like way of being less depressed that's
important
now that's where the work starts not
where it ends pomp and i think this is
important right because
then what happens is how do you keep
people there
how do you enable people to have the
sense of well-being
more good days on being present for bad
days but not viewing them as a life
sentence
you know this idea of
staying in a well-being zone and some
people
relapse right the thought patterns pick
up again
life experience something might happen
etc so we need to be able to predict
relapse and then we need to prevent it
so
four ps well actually three first
personalize predict and prevent
and our goal is to create the tools and
information to enable health systems to
do that
the tools might be things like
psilocybin as we're developing to the
highest global standard
of comp 360. it might be how to use that
effectively with different patient
populations different therapies
different doses
and it's to understand how long it lasts
for whom
and who benefits and who may not and
to then really be able to be a compass
for health systems and individuals of
where are they relative to their true
north of
personal well-being where is the
population doing so depressed patients
are they doing in better
as a whole or not if i'm a payer or if
i'm an insurer
do they have less or fewer
other kinds of diseases you know a lot
of people do self-soothing when they're
depressed
there's metabolic disease cardiovascular
disease that emerges
addictions you know all these things
that kind of go apart and
parcel with depression do we make a
difference in those do people have
richer fuller lives
so understanding that understanding the
impact of this not just on depression
but on one's life
i think this becomes really important
and then that leads us to be
how do you be a responsible participant
in a system like that
well you don't charge for therapy and
you don't charge for pills right you
actually become a partner with systems
to say
we'll improve outcomes i we'll do that
over time
and if we're doing that we should get
paid through some of the savings
if we don't do that we shouldn't get
paid because our job is to be
identifying and doing the research to
understand who will benefit
so this is happening in oncology so it's
not a wacky idea it's not crazy
um it just hasn't really been applied
here and so
what happens is you have therapy you
have medicine you have
technology to help support people
provide
you have data all those things need to
come together into a rich
tapestry of information for people so
that they can
personalize predict and ultimately
prevent relapse
so i feel sometimes i give two big
answers or too long but
you know our vision is really to help
people who are deeply suffering
starting with treatment resistant
depression so-called
and then to expand into other areas
always following data
always doing it in the highest
responsible way from our point of view
and opening to share that those data to
help inform people to deliver service
our view is not we don't want to be
delivering care we want to make the care
that's delivered
as best as it possibly can i love this
vision i think you guys are
well on your way to uh to accomplishing
it so uh
i am cheering you on before i uh let you
guys
i always ask the same two questions to
everyone and then you'll get to ask me
one to finish up
the first is just what is the most
important book that you've ever read
that's a really really hard one
i would probably say today
zen in the art of motorcycle maintenance
and why is that well someone who is
really struggling
with these these issues of
how to think about the world how to
participate in the world
um and also someone who is deeply
involved in the pursuit of the ideal of
quality what is quality
and i think that those two things
understanding the human experience of
someone really struggling
and to really understand what does
quality mean how do we deliver it in the
most responsible way
it was really formative for me to just
think about those things i could give
you a bunch of other books but
right now that was the answer for today
i love that it's just a great one uh
second question is more fun
aliens are you a believer or a
non-believer
you didn't ask if i was one
you got to work on these questions
ponder
look i think that it's hard for me to
fathom
that were here alone uh so aliens you
know
um are there other cultures other things
and other places beyond our knowledge
i'd be hard-pressed to say i have
evidence there aren't
i i tend to agree with
all right you could ask me one question
to finish up what do you got for me
what's driving your interest and
commitment to talk to people like me in
this area at this time
yeah look just learning i i think that
uh you know i'm in a very fortunate
position where i get to
spend all day just finding and talking
to the most
interesting uh and successful people in
the world and so sometimes that's
through
investing sometimes that's through uh
things like the podcast
but uh to me it's just learning it
literally is an intellectual curiosity
uh and kind of a commitment to lifelong
learning and so you know even our
conversation today i walk away with
multiple things
that i learn that i have to now go think
about and ponder about
and it's personally rewarding for me
because obviously i'm
extracting a ton of value but at the
same time i think that
doing it in this format rather than just
having private conversations but
recording them and kind of sharing them
it allows for other people to learn
alongside me which i think people
appreciate
and also it gives the guest a platform
to kind of spend an hour of their time
or so and and really get
their message and kind of their
learnings out to
uh as many people as possible and so
it's one of those rare cases in life
where you can kind of align
you know a win-win-win for multiple
groups and so
it's fun and i'll i'll keep doing this
until uh
you know one day i'll just wake up and
say hey that's it fun ride i'll see you
guys later
i guess at some point we all do that
i really appreciate your time and and
your interest in this um
at some point i'd love to come back and
share what we're learning as we get more
data over the course of the year and uh
i think um really grateful for your
dedication to this and helping get this
message out
we don't have to suffer in the way that
we have
in the past absolutely where can we send
people to find
either you on the internet or find out
more about compass
i'm kind of busy so i actually don't do
a lot of
social media but you can learn
everything about our company at
compasspathways.com
and yeah we're heads down
a great team working hard so you'll see
probably follow us on our website it's
probably the easiest way to do that
we have a section of news and you can
see what we're up to at all times
awesome well george listen thank you so
much for your time today i think people
really learned a lot from this
as i did and we'll do it again in the
future
lovely thanks paul be well